speaking of crimes on tinder the toronto
sun reports a woman recently found out
that it violates tinder law to appear as
a
dot dot dot
clown
jess harkin got kicked off the app for
posing in clown makeup
the thing is she's a professional clown
and her real name or no her clown name
is kazoo
and she just wanted to find love and
maybe another clown out there
to match up with and tinder claim that
she was violating their
terms of use i cannot
believe that you can be a tindler
swindler but not a clown yeah she
appealed and got her profile back so she
showed herself in her outfit for work if
she was a chef and showed her in a chef
hat right this is what this is who she
is
she's a clown and honestly aren't there
people who do up their instagram so much
with so much makeup that it's like a
clown it's just that their face is not a
clown face that's some good shade
that's some good shade every normal that
is yes because some of these people be
wearing
too much makeup i'm just like where is
the line anymore you can't be a clown on
tinder would you date a clown
i think i have yeah
all right
next up
i love this or anybody here ever have
trouble getting online like your
internet's out or something we've all
been there well a french dad is in some
hot water now for trying to keep his
kids off the internet the new york post
reports he set up a scrambler to block
wi-fi in his house from midnight to 3am
to keep his kids from scrolling the
night away which sounds sort of smart
right but the problem is it worked but a
little too well
because it blocked the internet for the
entire town yes not only that several
surrounding towns as well
and now he reportedly faced fines and
even six months in prison
if he's found guilty i mean it started
out kind of smart you know my kid's
staying up late scrolling so let me turn
the internet off except you know oops
i love him i if i could stop my kids
from doom scrolling from midnight till
3am i would totally do so he well he can
yeah can i just say something
it is against the law it is against the
law in france it is against the law in
america it is against the law to use a
jamming device to stop the the
reception of cellular service here's how
you stop the kids from doom scrolling
this is the phone you take it
oh
that's easier it's so much easier and
guaranteed it will not land you in jail
thank you clearly all right deborah
what's next well speaking of jail this
is a bear that needs to be in jail cnn
is reporting there's a big giant bear
that is breaking into houses in lake
tahoe california he is apparently very
hungry and he
has he's obviously eaten a lot his
nickname is hank the tank estimated to
run at around oh 500 pounds he's been
accused of breaking into at least 28
homes but now there's new evidence it
says that hank actually might not be a
solo operator there's dna evidence you
can speculate what that might be
that shows that there may be a whole
bunch of bears responsible for the
break-ins and local residents say he
just kind of sits there and eats he
doesn't attack he doesn't growl he
doesn't make ugly faces he just eats
hank the tank on the loose oh wow what
do we do i love hank i think he's just
you know looking for goldilocks just for
payback you know what i mean house by
house by house trying to find her what
if this is like a crazy news
sadistic diet for keeping you if the key
the guy took all the internet away so
his kids wouldn't be up from midnight to
3am i can go to the refrigerator
and do some real damage and if i thought
there was a 500 pound bear in the
kitchen i might think twice yeah so
maybe we should just all imagine that
hank the tank is hanging out in our
kitchen right when we want to go and
self-sabotage yes your thighs will
appreciate the best diet ever
new diet alert there's a bear in your
kitchen
[Music]
you